it's a long way from home but at least
here Irene gangte is safe
she had to flee her hometown of imphal
when violence broke out between the
majority Hindu mate and the kooky
communities living in this part of India
a nurse back home she's putting her
skills in good use in this Relief Center
situation
the situation is serious and both
communities are gravely divided
non-tribals have left tribal areas so
the non-tribals have come to the Empire
Valley and the tribals have gone to the
hills they did it for their safety
at least 115 people have been killed and
50 000 others displaced since the ethnic
Strife started at the beginning of May
the cookies are minority tribe in
Manipur state in Northeast India they
are officially designated as scheduled
tribe which gives them preferential
access to jobs and education
the violence started After manipur's
High Court recommended that the metis
majority be awarded the same designation
and benefits many in the meyte community
had long resented the Privileges awarded
to the cookies
Holmes churches temples and government
institutions were attacked the cookies
say they have paid the highest price so
far
you cannot be with the middies anymore
the trust has failed it's going to take
another decades to build that trust
between the two communities
the minority cookies accuse the state
government of siding with the metis
some 40 000 security forces have been
deployed but tensions remain high as
efforts to disarmed vigilante groups
from both sides have proven difficult
and normal life has been thrown out of
gear says
he runs a service point but with daily
curfews and the internet shut down for
weeks now is difficult to run the
business
this is the time for new admissions for
students they need internet to access
results or to apply to colleges outside
they needed to submit their fees those
looking for jobs have to submit the
forms there are also facing problems
the cookies are now demanding for
separate Administration the visit of the
opposition leader Rahul Gandhi is part
of his five months long Unity march
across India but here in Manipur Unity
is more elusive than ever